thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of careful boys we have with us today Mr
Jason Cheney oh
what a good time
I like that you're coming back so often
man I like it thank you so much for
everybody likes it thank you guys so
much for having me
I really appreciate the room yeah thank
you guys you belong here
and then and then you're welcome not
like some other people
who are those people we have guests in
the past before where I never want them
back ever again and then I'm just like I
thought they would have been so good I
feel like he always brings that up when
you're here yeah who who are those
people yeah right now who are some
guests that you would not want back
after these messages
[Laughter]
what I wanted to know because this is a
thing that I'm always curious about do
you have any in your own personal lives
you guys have any Unsolved Mysteries
hell yeah bro things that happen to you
why
I can't say it yeah because it drinks it
or is it because like it's too personal
it's still an under investigation and if
I say it then the people involved will
be notified and they'll get scared and
they'll cover their tracks oh my God so
I don't want them to know that okay okay
that's already too much yeah and there's
put it on patreon I say more there's a
few things like that where I don't like
to talk about it
because when you do then the person
involved well so like sometimes it'll
bring them out of the darkness right
like so sometimes it's very risky when
you corner someone or something and then
they know you're on to take
countermeasures yeah then they'll cover
but then you know who it is yeah but
then
what if there's more than if you suspect
there's more than one involved
you're gonna that they're gonna alert
the other person and all that right
right so then when I'm in the middle of
Investigations
um I don't want that to be known okay
yeah did anybody have any Unsolved
Mysteries that um you can't talk about
yeah
one of them so I think I told the first
half of the story
um I remember when I was like I think
like 14 or 15. I was in Taiwan and my
grandparents place and I was looking
through a old photo album and like my my
on my mom's side they kept really good
records of just photos like there's tons
of them even like photos of my grandma
when she was small like crazy black and
white photos which is super cool
and then I was going to the back of the
photo album and then I see my mom's like
junior high or high school ID and it was
there and then her name is a different
name to talk and I'm like what the [ __ ]
and I'm like hey Grandpa like who the
[ __ ] is this
oh that's your mom she didn't tell you
she changed her name and I was like no
like up to my like 15 I thought my mom's
name was this than Chinese you know and
I'm like what the [ __ ] so I just felt
like I've been lied to you when your
parents are like tell the truth dude you
ain't never lie you know all that kind
of [ __ ] and I'm like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
been lion so when I when I came back to
America because my mom was at home that
was like the first thing that was on my
mind like in LAX I forgot who dropped me
off I get back to my mom's house and I'm
like
I said Blake is not your name the [ __ ]
is your real name [ __ ] Bourne
Identity [ __ ] and then uh oh no you
don't understand I was gonna tell you
what's I'm like oh yeah well you're
gonna tell me what are we gonna tell me
and um so I don't know the mystery
behind it my own like assumptions is uh
I do know my mom was married before my
dad at one point and so I think like in
a lot of I don't know if this is like
correcting Taiwanese culture but it
almost feels like any time like you [ __ ]
up to kind of get a reset people will
just change your name
I never even heard of this well because
my family does it all the time
what the [ __ ] cousin has a different
name after he got kicked out of so many
places and was about to get locked up in
jail so when he came here
[ __ ] just find new X-Men to
bless them with new names and [ __ ] wow
but that makes sense you are now Rogue
now like oh dude Nick you know you're
you're Nick the nose now and then you're
not a fighter he's ripped the nose yeah
break the nose it's like my mom like
knows dude my mom uh my marriage didn't
work out I know kids though oh my God
what a new start and that's the new
start that she got I think it is so she
so she had a birth name that her that
her parents gave her she got married she
changed her last name because
she she got married to a new family
right yeah and then that didn't work out
she got a divorce so she changed
everything to a whole new name all three
letters changed did you know about like
in Chinese it's like three
but what it is I think shameful all
three of them changed Jay Sean bone
[Laughter]
now you give me a complex
[Laughter]
dude
he's sitting over there [ __ ] massage
that's a hot Mystery by the way yeah and
my mom isn't even someone you can like
um
have like an investigative you can't
confront her about it journalist session
about oh because she's [ __ ] cuckoo
you can't just ask her why did you
change your name
say it like that because she [ __ ]
Coco ass [ __ ] okay what would she say
ask me a question okay why why did you
have a different name because the
dragons told me
[Laughter]
you know like you know in her world is
different than my world
but to her when did she think when she
watched shangshi what does she thinks
she thought it was a history lesson
remember when this happened my mom
doesn't know my mom yeah she's crazy
she has a lot of spirituals when she's
driving a car I think she believes it's
the dragon I'll Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon she's writing that into the like
wow sweet lady but her logic and
reasoning is not based on logic and
reasoning
[Laughter]
somehow she believed that I was I was an
orphaned with no parents when I told her
I do have a mom she's in Japan and then
she goes no now I am your mom yeah and
then I'm all like that's cool Mommy
you're gonna bring me food and do all
this [ __ ] like whatever like yeah true
he said you call me Mom now and then she
she made she basically adopted me but
she's a shitty adoptive parent because
after that moment she did no mother
duties never brought me she just told me
I'm your mom that's it and she doesn't
pray so she's a bad day she abandoned me
every day yeah dude I bet you she even
forgot that she was my mom but she for
that moment though she adopted she had
good intentions for that day yes that's
so sweet Dragon told her to stop yeah
you uh care what is Mystery number two
for you that's for this number one
mystery number two is my parents got
divorced when I was six and since then
I've never known the truth of what
really happened and when I got older and
I was explaining to my mom I hate that
because I remember that day vividly when
my dad left the door
um but I don't even remember like the
time of day when I try to get accounts
from both parents one they're like pull
the Opposites oh it was in the morning
and this happened it was in the kitchen
like okay cool and I talked to my dad
when did that happen it was at night and
it was in the living room so like both
accounts are completely off and I'm like
I don't even know who to believe so it's
just been like oh my big giant question
mark on like how it started why it
started what happened so for them it was
like we had a fight that day and then it
was done yeah and then one was like we
fought in the kitchen and the other
one's like nah we found a living room
yeah like my mom looked like your dad
sent me divorce papers and I'm like oh
[ __ ] I just ask my dad he goes your mom
hired a voice lawyer yeah she called me
oh what because they're just way off
we're not even like it's not even like
the Departed and like infertile Affairs
you to see how one's inspired by the
other right this is too much can you ask
them to be
yeah I appreciated that one Wow way off
I'm like dude you guys could at least
plagiarize a little bit
you can ask them to be honest I did like
the dad like please be honest
natural truth you know what I mean
your personal theories
stuff it was in the bathroom well well
yeah when I got older
I just think like and with the knowledge
we know now about like mental health and
[ __ ] like that I think they're probably
just two really disgruntled people that
somehow found each other that I should
never have been together and then they
were trying to make something work to
fit Society because you know like back
then like if you're like in the early
30s that's already considered old so you
better find someone they got married in
their early 30s
yeah oh wow yeah so they're like and so
I think they were just trying to force
something to fit in society not be an
outcast and make things work so I don't
like put any like blame on them but I
think uh
it was just a recipe for disaster yeah
that's a that's a very sad story
do I really care I don't think I really
care but sometimes you wonder a little
bit a little bit but then it doesn't
affect my life now
let's say I got the truth yeah and then
I'm like nothing happens I'm like uh
it's my parents are still cuckoo yeah
yeah yeah like that made me sad a little
bit oh I did it yeah okay no I'm sorry
yeah some some personal guys
I mean I had one that was really stupid
compared to that yeah yeah
so one time uh when I was living in
Irvine and uh I was I was in the car
with Victor and we were just trying to
parallel park
and then
um for some weird reason for a little
parking we both heard me run over
something and we heard it go
laughs and we were like we looked at
each other we were like what the [ __ ]
was that for a homeless man yeah we
thought it was like an elf or some [ __ ]
it we really went we heard it Go audibly
perfectly because my windows were down
if something went and so we went oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] was that we looked out
there we got out immediately and there
was nothing there yeah
it felt like we ran something over so we
both got out and it there was nothing
there that's it
that's what we thought we ran over we
thought we ran over a gnome or do you
think a guy saw you hit a bump and he
went
[Applause]
and he was walking by I don't know it's
just such a dumb thing but that's
something that I always wanted to know
what the [ __ ] did we run over like what
was this frog like a little toad and
there was no Splat there's no it was
perfectly clean it was totally clean we
got out we we looked under the car and
to like if I ran into Victor now we he
would probably go did you ever figure
out what that was like we thought about
it for so long
you know that might have been stupider
but I gotta say that mystery has got me
going way more like what
there's a
there's actually come to think of it
several Unsolved Mysteries that happened
within the last month one is
um so when we were doing construction at
jumbi
um
we we had two break-ins one is solved we
got we had oh wow well the first one we
think it was an inside job because
um
damn
when my um this isn't the thing that you
wanna like clear them out no no this one
is kind of solved oh okay but but the
but the second part is the crazy part so
like so the first part is um
you know when when all of the guys were
at lunch they they left the door
unlocked so we saw the account uh they
saw the camera uh security footage and
they see like a construction guy kind of
standing there and then he's by the door
and then and then he like a few seconds
later he walks away and another guy just
immediately goes inside
and then grabs my buddies like iPad and
headphones and he walks immediately out
so he knew where everything was and that
took less than a couple minutes
and then
um so that one was like well like
obviously it was probably inside but no
one knows right no one could confirm
the second one was the alarm went off
early in the morning like several weeks
after and then uh he sent me pictures of
the door the barricade door was busted
through it looked like someone kicked
the door all that [ __ ] right and for
some reason the security footage is
missing and it's inconclusive and they
don't know what the [ __ ] happened yeah
but nothing was stolen I mean like
nothing was taken everything was fine
and we're just like what the hell just
happened because the security footage
like
was completely fine the last time there
was some kind of break-in but then this
time it was like a clear when you see
the uh the door it looked like someone
kicked it and busted through so that was
taken that guy broke back in he tried to
delete the security footage but he
didn't realize it was a different day
it was it was it was actually about a
month after
that was all [ __ ] up that made me
think of one that happened to me
recently and this is the reason why I
got cameras so tell us about your gas
leak again
it was a different video
[Laughter]
after this it was when I was like okay I
got some ring cameras
um I wake up in the morning and
Tiff says she finds out her car was like
broken into someone opened her car
because she had a bag a Target bag that
she bought a I think a bikini from
Target or something
and she was going to return it if she
didn't she ended up having cold feet if
you don't want to get it
so she was like hey did you take my
target bag and I was like no I didn't
take it she goes it's missing from the
car
and I go are you sure that's where you
put it she goes yeah it was for sure in
the car and then she goes and then
there's a phone
in the car is this your phone and it was
just like an Android
so it was an Android that was on the
front seat of the car oh [ __ ]
we don't know whose [ __ ] phone it was
it was it was still on I had battery it
was like it was locked so we couldn't
open it
but the she has a lot of [ __ ] in the car
but the guy I guess the guy broke in
opened the door and his phone fell out
yeah phone fell out he only took
yeah and on the front there's just a
jacket on our gate our front gate
and we go
what the [ __ ] is this and we're piecing
it together as we're finding all this so
in our head this is like the creepiest
[ __ ] thing ever yeah look at this
dude's phone I'm assuming it's a guy and
my theory is is that he was like
checking car doors he opened his car
door bought saw this target bag saw a
receiving there wanted to return it
maybe get some cash and he [ __ ] left
his phone and his jacket and he just put
his jacket on the front gate because he
was putting on the bikini okay this one
also makes sense yeah it's so clear yeah
he was just he literally goes in he
takes off his jacket puts it there he's
like oh I'm gonna put on his bikini he's
like I feel really bad because I'm
taking this and I'm gonna leave my phone
that's it dude mystery song
what a nice guy that is really weird at
the time we were so like all right this
is [ __ ] up like this is really crazy
this is kind of yeah putting the pieces
together feels weird but then afterwards
you're like oh it's probably just like a
homeless dude yeah if it's if it's on
this guy with an Android plan that's
right well I think I feel like everyone
has a phone now yeah well if it's a
homeless guy with a phone then it's
probably gonna be an Android it's
definitely not gonna be an iPhone
shots fired but I have the phone still
in my house and I'm just like I look at
every now and I'm like
[Music]
yeah you can charge it and then you
could sell it
okay I didn't buy a bikini with it I
just remembered a really good one
because I have a really good theory as
to what happened but um when I was 17 I
was having a party at my parents house
it was all like high school friends 30
of us right we're all hanging out and
stuff there was like a maybe like a 10
to 15 minute window where I wasn't
really in my room but someone else was
and then we go into my room and there's
just a giant like pool of blood in my
bed oh it's a period That's a chick
somebody's having sex and they [ __ ]
had a period and then yeah like it was
it went all the way down to the through
the sheets into the mattress and then I
remember getting we got all the friends
together and we were like who the [ __ ]
bled all over the bed like and nobody
wanted to admit it's period juice yeah
no good one but all the girls all the
girls agreed to help wash it
oh it's for sure girl code dude that's
girl code right there but the thing is
is like why would someone just have a
[ __ ] period what I what I really
think happened is that one of them like
lost their virginity at that moment on
the bed how much blood that much blood a
lot of blood is a big dick it was more
than period blood I don't know I don't
know
I don't know how much blood comes out
the guys were like I was [ __ ] that
[ __ ] so hard
whoever the woman was limping that was
the one nobody nobody ever fessed up to
it but I think all the girls all the
girls knew and there was like seven of
them I think all of them knew that it
was one of them so they all agreed to be
like oh let's all and then they washed
it together that's really nice though
they wash my sheets they all they all
took one side like a kid playing the
[ __ ] parachute game in elementary
school all the guys were like oh but all
the girls were like oh shut up we could
just clean it and they'd all like work
together like all you got to do is spray
it and then scrub it but there's no way
it's cleaned it's blood yeah nobody ever
like festivals I don't know did you get
the stain out no way wait it doesn't
come out it just [ __ ] looks like
coffee afterwards yeah white sheets well
I don't they were blue but yeah
I never figured out what that was but
then I don't know who did it I have an
idea that who might have done it I think
it was you you know who I'm looking at
yeah
I I have a stupid one can I say yeah I
love stupid words okay
um but this is why now I uh I I always
want people to believe me because of
this event because I always feel like
people don't believe me okay because
when I was younger it traumatized me
this event and there's a stupid one
um I think I was in fifth grade or
fourth grade
uh the the toilet
um they wanted to fix the toilet it was
in Taiwan and uh my mom's like don't
don't flush the toilet oh no no no no no
no no she's like make sure to flush the
toilet oh okay okay make sure to flush
the toilet all right okay make sure to
flush the toilet
[Laughter]
and then I go my dad goes to the
bathroom right easy either before or
after me I know he went after me but I
go first I take a [ __ ] all right there's
[ __ ] in the toilet now okay yeah so then
I flush the toilet there's no [ __ ] my
dad goes in the bathroom and then comes
out and then my mom goes in after like
30 minutes and go why didn't you flush
the toilet and then I'm like I flushed
the toilet and she's like no you didn't
there's [ __ ] in the in the in the toilet
bowl
and I was like but I flushed it dad also
went to the bathroom
and then and I was crying because she
doesn't believe me that I would never
forget that I'm I oh I would think about
I can set you up dude I think about this
once a month that I'm like why doesn't
my mom just believe that I flushed
there's no I flushed my [ __ ] why would I
not flush my [ __ ] who in the who is like
I'm not gonna flush my [ __ ] who forgets
to flush [ __ ] your dad that's what I'm
saying I said I said but Dad went in and
Dad's like no I did it and then Mom if I
forgot it why did your dad do that I
don't know but I was like Dad but he's
like I really didn't think I did it too
I'm like so they're just magic it's just
magic that you have to sit down with
them and be like look remember that time
you [ __ ] do you remember things
but they don't remember the thing and
everyone once a month I think about this
I was like why don't they believe me
a big deal to your mom
whatever who cares whose [ __ ] is that
because she said you'd flush the toy you
make sure you flush the toilet that day
something something with that day and
then um but they don't trust me anyways
I don't know why did you tell your
parents that you think about this once a
month no but now I will
yeah sorry it's a stupid watch no that's
a good experience either your dad's
lying or he or he legitimately flushed
it and then she just came back up yeah
about that what else could he lie about
yeah exactly thank you
foreign